dilash oh my god what do you say I think
the story is people telling you
especially in America is of a superhero
but when I read his book I thought this
is the best superhero I think we'd all
do this we might die some of us some of
us might live I would not give up some
of us during the process of doing what
he has to do but we'd all do it because
we're all the same basically I have 150
milliliters of water left which keep me
alive tilt row Nate well 127 hours is
the story of Aron Ralston entrapment in
a canyon in southern Utah
he gets trapped by a rock on his right
hand he is there for 127 hours for six
days and five nights and this story is
about what happens to him during that
time and how he manages to finally
extricate himself this guy walks in as a
supreme individual he's self-sufficient
completely independent of need anybody
crimes 14,000 foot peaks in winter so
low he runs ultra marathons in the
desert he's a supreme individual he's
quite interesting some wilderness people
of course don't like this kind of guy
cuz he heads into the wilderness and
it's just blaring music the whole time
cuz he got he's in the wilderness in
this great place of Sun so he's got
headphones off he has a bike crusher at
the beginning of the film nobody just
laughed it off and keeps on biking you
know he really just think he is
absolutely unbeatable you know you
didn't tell anyone where you were going
what in their nature steps in and with a
pebble the equivalent of a pebble or a
grain of sand just stops him in his
tracks tries all the physical stuff to
get out of there and none of it works he
has to examine what he's like he
examines the people in his life that he
has not as he admits respect him as much
as he should have done or appreciated in
his heart as much as he could have done
mom dad I haven't appreciated you as I
know that I could I love you guys and
I'll always be with you he accepts
actually but it's his destiny to meet
this rock he figures out he thinks this
is meant to be isn't it I just thought
this out I've deliberately phoned the
remotest place I can in Western America
and actually I've actually come here to
find this rock haven't I
it gives him a modesty and a grace
really in a way that he's liked maybe
previously in his individual
achievements and it shows him the key
the way out of them do not give up he
had a camera and stills camera and
they're exactly the ones that he took in
there with him and he left a series of
messages so the messages he left which
Aaron did agree to show James and I are
extraordinary because they are not what
you'd expect they're not abject and
distressing they're actually a man
trying to leave a dignified impression
so that when his mom views his last
statements really after he's been found
she wouldn't be too upset that's what he
was trying to achieve we shot for a week
in the real Canyon in Blue John Canyon
we had to camp there because you can't
clearly travel in and out so we camped
there for a week and shot there and then
we repeated the canyon in a warehouse in
Salt Lake City
because it's it's dangerous to film in
the real place for all sorts of reasons
not just to do with flash floods when
there's one of those in the film that
you see but also to do with crew getting
lost when you take 40 people into an
area like that
some EJ wanders off you know it meets a
snake or something you know that all
those kind of probabilities suddenly
multiply so we shot we repeated the
exact canyon and its dimensions and also
it's restricted
yes because we didn't make it a floating
set which they normally doing when they
build sets we kept it very very
constrictive so that the style of the
film is dictated by how little room
there is it's only possible for one
cameraman to be in the spot with him
there was no more room for anybody else
to do anything we also reduced James to
tears nearly because he was not allowed
to use his right hand under any
circumstances because it's absolutely
pinned under there and he was
extraordinary the performance of James
Franco of the way he went about it the
way he embraced this reductive nature of
can you make a film with nothing really
in a way because it must never become
inert you know it must always be moving
in terms of the emotional journey he's
on anybody who would be trapped like
that he's gonna be having pop songs
running through their head the whole
time like worm songs you know like
getting to it and you can't get him out
your brain and this morning he starts a
new day with the Bill Withers song
lovely day which is a great song
great happy song about a beautiful day
and of course he's in the most appalling
circumstances but he tries to keep his
spirits up you know so you can
illustrate it through both ironic use of
music and enforcing sound and silence
there's no comic relief character coming
in to freshen things up there's no
villain coming in to change the mood he
is all those things you can help him
with music and with the rhythm of the
editing but it's up to James really and
what was extraordinary was I remember
seeing him in pineapple express and that
was the film that made me think this is
him because it's the same as DeNiro
I remember seeing DeNiro in King a
comedy and I'd seen the intense films
and then you see him do comedy we think
mats of truly rounded actor